بعد ساعه من توجيه اتهامات له ترامب يقول
ان الادله زائفه ويطالب بمقاضات النائب
العام
رغبه فرنسيه امريكيه في اشراك الصين
بعمليه تسريع انهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا
وبغداد واربيل واقعان اتفاقا يقضي باداره
تصدير نفط الاقليم عبر بغداد
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
قال الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق دونالد ترامب
في كلمته الاولى او من مارلاجو فعلا بعد
مثوله امام المحكمه بمنعه قال ان
الديمقراطيين هاجموه بشكل شخصي
وحاولوا النيل منه بتحقيقات زائفه لا اساس
لها من الصحه
ترامب اضاف انه لم يكن يتوقعوا ان يمثل
بهذه الطريقه امام المحكمه وان القضيه
التي رفع ضده هدفها او هدفها التاثير على
انتخابات 2024 مؤكدا على ضروره اسقاطها
فورا
الى او في كلمته الى عدم الوثوق بالادله
التي قدموها ضده في المحكمه لافتا الى ان
نظام القضائيه فقد قانونيته
هذه حمله موجهه شخصيا ضدي وليست تحقيقا
المدعي العام الفاشل يوجه اتهامات ضد رئيس
امريكي سابق امر يحصل لاول مره في التاريخ
ويستخدم في ذلك ادله غير قانونيه لا توجد
هنا قضيه قانونيه ضدي القضيه باطله لا
يمكن الوثوق بالادله التي قدموها ضد في
المحكمه والمجرم الحقيقي هنا هو مدعي عامه
الفنبراج الذي يجب مقاضاته وعليه تقديم
استقالته فورا
القضيه المرفوعه ضد هدفها التاثير على
انتخابات 2024
عرضنا طواعيه على مكتب التحقيقات الاطلاع
على الوثائق السريه التي كانت في منزلي في
مرالاجو واستعادتها هذه الوثائق كانت
بحوزه بشكل قانوني احضرتها خلال فتره
كرئيس وبعلم الجميع وهذا امر فعله كل رئيس
امريكي سبقني وكنت اتعامل بحسن نيه الى ان
هاجم الاف بي اي منزلي هذا يبرهن ان
النظام القضائي الامريكي فقد قانونيته
وانهم يحاولون سرقه الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
لم اعتقد ابدا ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث
في الولايات المتحده جريمه الوحيده هي
الدفاع عن البلاد ضد من يحاول تدميرها كما
تذكرون الديمقراطيون تجسس على حمله
الانتخابيه منذ البدايه وحاولوا النيل مني
بتحقيقات زائفه لا اساس لها من الصحه
وهاجموني بشكل شخصي
وكانت محكمه منهاتنا الجنائيه منحت الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دون ترامب اطلاقه سراح
غير مشروط وكانت رامب نافان يكون مذنبا في
34 اتهاما تم توجيههم اليه من قادم هاته
وذلك بعد ان رفعت المحكمه فيمنعه السريه
عن رائحه اتهام ترامب وتهنى مدعيا منها
بالتامر كما نفى الرئيس الامريكي السابق
تقديم ريشه لشراء سكوت امراتين
ايضا تزوير سجلت تجاريه قبل انتخابات عام
من جهه
محامي رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
انه لا توجد مؤشرات على ارتكاب ترامب لاي
جريمه فيدراليه
لا توجد مؤشرات على ارتكاب الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب لاي جريمه فيدراليه ان اتهام
الرئيس السابق امر محبط ومحزن ويؤكد ان
سياده القانون ماتت في هذا البلد
متهم بتزوير سجلات تجاريه لاخفاء معلومات
عن الناخبين وهو متهم باخفاء معلومات سريه
خلال فتره رئاسته كما حاول تقويض نزاهه
انتخابات عام 2016 ومن بين تهامه التي
اشار لها مدعي عاما هاتن قيام الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق بتزوير سجلات الاعمال ضمن
نشاط جنائيا سري واضاف مدعي من هاتن
لتهامات موجهه لترامب تتضمن شرائه صمت
امراتين وعامل سابق في برجه حول انجاب طفل
خارج الزواج
اصدرت سنتر بيانا بشان رائحه اتهام الرئيس
السابق
وقال سنتر الجمهوري في تغريده على تويتر
قال ان شخصيه ترامب وسلوكه جعل منه شخصا
غير مناسبا لموقع الرئاسه في الولايات
المتحده
في تغريدته على ان لا احد فوق القانون ولا
حتى الرؤساء السابقون مؤكدا ان لكل فرد
الحق في معامله متساويه بموجب القانون
اعلنا قصر الاليزي في بيانا ان الرئيس
الفرنسي من والمقام والرئيسه الامريكي جو
بعيدا تحدث في اتصال هاتفي عن رغبتهما
المشتركه في اشراك الصين في تسريع انهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا والمشاركه في بناء سلام
دائما في المنطقه
قوه جديده تضاف الى حلف الناتو لتكون
فنلندا الدوله 31 في الحلف لتلحق بها
السويد وربما اوكرانيا ايضا ما يزيد من
التوترات الحدوديه بين روسيا ودول الحلف
المتاخمه
فخلي عن الحياد العسكري الذي تبنته فنلندا
لعقود يضيف عضوا جديدا لحلف النيتو لتصبح
ما مجموعه 31 دوله حدود تشاركها فنلندا مع
روسيا بطول 1300 كيلومتر لم تعد حدود حياد
بل جبهه شماليه لحلف النيتو وجبهه اقوى
لتتشارك روسيا الان
2600 كيلومتر مع اربع من دول الحلف
قوه اضافيه كسبها الحلف فبالرغم من حيادها
لم تخفض فنلندا ميزانيه الدفاع منذ الحرب
البارده ليتحول بحر البلطيق الى منطقه
نفود للنيتو بانتظار انضمام السويد التي
تواجه مشكله مع تركيا خطوه ستزيد من عدد
قوات الحلف المنتشره شرق اوروبا تحديدا
على الحدود المشتركه مع روسيا الى ما
يقارب 300 الف جندي ما قد تراه موسكو
التصعيدا يدفعها الى فعل مماثل بعسكره
حدودها وهو ما بدا جليا في تصريحات
الكريملين
يرى الكرملين ان ذلك تفاقم اخر للوضع
وانها توسع النيتو تعدا على امننا ومصالح
روسيا الاتحاديه ننظر الى ذلك بهذه
الطريقه بالضبط وسنتخذ تدابير مضاده لضمان
امننا التكتيكي والاستراتيجي باب يتركه
حلف النيتو مفتوحا رغم التهديدات الروسيه
لتمر عبره السويد قريبا وربما اوكرانيا
لاحقا ما قد يفجر غضبا روسيا من نوع جديد
او يضع حدا لطموح موسكو التوسعي الى عمر
العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
اعتداءات اسرائيليه على المصلين في المسجد
الاقصى والقبه الحديديه تعترض صواريخ
اطلقت من غزه
اهلا بكم من جديد قصف الطائرات اسرائيليه
موقعا في قطاع غزه فيما هجمت وحدات من
الشرطه الاسرائيليه عددا من الفلسطينيين
داخل المسجد القبلي في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك واطلقت الشرطه قنابل الغاز
والرصاص المطاطي باتجاه الفلسطينيين في
محاوله لاخراجهم من المسجد وكان دعوات
شبابيه مختلفه قد دعت جموع الناس الى
الاعتكاف في المسجد الاقصى لصديق اقتحامات
متوقعه للمستوطنين الاسرائيليين اليوم
الاربعاء
[موسيقى]
كما شهدت العديد من احياء القدس والمدن
والمخيمات الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
مواجهات مع القوات الاسرائيليه عقب
تظاهرات شعبيه خرجت للتنديد بالقمع الذي
تعرض له معتكفون داخل المسجد الاقصى وفيما
قالت الشرطه الاسرائيليه انها اعتقلت
العشرات من داخل المسجد حذر الناطق باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيله بردانه اسرائيل
من تجاوز الخطوط الحمر في الاماكن المقدسه
والتي من شانها ان تؤدي الى انفجار كبير
على حد وصفه
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان انها
تتابع بقلق بالغ عمليه اقتحام قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لباحات المسجد الاقصى
ودانت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان هذا
الاعتداء الذي وصفته بالسافر وعبرت عن
رفضها القاطع لهذه الممارسات التي تقوض
جهود السلام الخارجيه السعوديه جددت في
بيانها موقفها الراسخ في دعم الجهود
الراميه الى انهاء الاحتلال والوصول الى
حل شامل وعادل للقضيه الفلسطينيه
كما دانت الخارجيه المصريه في بيان اقتحام
الشرطه الاسرائيليه للمسجد الاقصى وما
صاحب ذلك من اعتداءات ادت الى وقوع اصابات
عديده بين المصلين واعتبرت مصر ان مثل هذه
الاعتداءات والانتهاكات المتكرره لحرمه
الاماكن المقدسه تؤجج مشاعر الغضب لدى
جميع ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني والشعوب
الاسلاميه الخارجيه المصريه طلبت السلطات
الاسرائيليه بالوقوف الفوري لتلك او الوقف
الفوري لتلك الاعتداءات وطلبت في بيانها
المجتمع الدولي بتحمل مسؤوليته في وضع حد
لتلك الاعتداءات وتجنيب المنطقه المزيد من
عوامل عدم الاستقرار والتوتر الخارجيه
الاردنيه من جانبها نددت بعمليه اقتحام
اسرائيل المسجد الاقصى ووصفته بالانتهاك
الصارخ
وقعت حكومه بغداد واقليم كردستان الجانبان
التو بالفعل وقع اتفاقيه تفضي باداره
بغداد ملف تصدير نفط كردستان العراق عبر
شركه تسويق الوطنيه على ان تشارك في اداره
هذا الملف
هذه هي الصهاريج التي تضم مخزونات نفط
كردستان الخام بعد توقفه لنحو اسبوع بسبب
قرارات المحكمه الفرنسيه ومن هنا ايضا
سيستانف اقليم كردستان تصديره للنفط بعد
اتفاقه المبرم مع بغداد ولاول مره
البيانات الصحفيه لحكومه اقليم كردستان
العراق اكدت ان رئيس الحكومه مسرور
بارزاني بتوقيعه الاتفاق مع الحكومه
الاتحاديه سيرسي اساسا نحو عهد جديد من
التعاون الثنائي المستمر بين اربيل وبغداد
بحسب البيان
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد هذه الاتفاقيه تصب في مصلحه
الشعب العراقي وهنا اود ان اشكركم وان
اهنئ شعب كردستان والشعب العراقي واؤكد
بان هذا الاتفاق سيكون اساسا مهما
للموازنه وحتى لقانون النفط والغاز ان تم
تنفيذه بشكل مضبوط بالتاكيد ان ايقاف
تصدير نفط كردستان كان مطرا للاقتصاد
العراقي ولم يكن مضرا لشعب كردستان فقط
هذا الاتفاق جاء حصيله حوار ونقاش استمر
لايام
وبروح مهنيه
وبرغبه صادقه حل مشكله الكل متضرر منها
وتقضي الاتفاقيه بان شركه التسويق سوما
الوطنيه هي من ستقوم بالاشراف على بيع نفط
اقليم كردستان بالاسعار ذاتها التي تبيعها
بغداد ما يشكل فارقا كبيرا بالاسعار كون
اقليم كردستان كان يبيعنا اخطاه باسعار
اقل من السوق العالميه هذا فضلا عن ان
نائبه مدير شركه التسويق سومو سيكون من
حصه الكرد بحسب الاتفاق هناك تفاؤل وهناك
الطابور خامس يريد ان يزيل هذا التفاؤل في
داخل شعب كردستان ولكن الحقيقه واضحه لن
تحجبها اشعه الشمس وضياء الشمس بها
الغربال مرحله جديده من الثقه المتبادره
في التعاطي مع جميع الملفات العالقه ما
بين اربيل وبغداد جسدتها مباحثات وصفت
بالشفافه لتنهي حقبه عقد من السجالات ما
بين الجانبين احمد الحمداني العربيه
اربيل
في السودان اعلنت القوى المدنيه الموقعه
على الاتفاق الايطالي في بيان عقب
اجتماعها لمناقشه تطورات السياسيه عن
استلامها نسخه مسوده
للاتفاق السياسي النهائي والتي اعدتها
لجنه صياغه بمشاركه جميع اعضائها
العسكريين والمدنيين مخدعه المسوده
للدراسه والنقاش لتصبح جاهزه فيما عدا
القضايا الفنيه المتبقيه في ملف الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري والتي اكد المجتمعون انها
تشهد تقدما ملموسا داخل اللجان الفنيه
المعنيه مع ضروره مضاعفه الجهد من اجل
تجاوز العقبه المتبقيه واكدت القوانيتها
الترتيب الاجتماع عاجلا للقوى العسكريه
والمدنيه الواقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
بهدف بحث العقبات المتبقيه بما يساهم في
توقيع الاتفاق السياسي النهائي باعجل ما
تيسر معتبره في الوقت نفسه ان نشاط
المتزايد لعناصر نظام المؤتمر الوطني
المحلول لتخريب العمليه السياسيه واشعال
الفتنه لن تفلح وان النظام الذي اسقطه
الشعب لن يعود مره اخرى
يشهد المسجد المسجد الحرام عمليات تنظيم
دقيقه لمئات الالاف من المعتمرين والمصلين
والزائرين في شهر رمضان
[موسيقى]
ام المسرح سيده الشاشه الخليجيه وبلا شك
ايقونه الدراما الكويتيه حياه الفهد نجمه
كما يقول الكتاب اثرت او الكتابه عفوا
الثلاث وطورت الدراما الخليجيه
[موسيقى]
ايش معنى اخترتيني انا علشان املي فراغ
وحدتي حسره
[موسيقى]
مرحبا انت قناه كبيره طالت النجمه حياه
الفهد قبل حتى ان يبدا الموسم الرمضاني
والسبب مسلسل قرت عينك حيث بدات
الانتقادات مع نشر البوستر الخاص بالعمل
واستمرت مع بدء عرضه الهجوم على حياه
الفهد هي حياه الفهد يعني اليوم احنا هي
قامت قبل عرض الرسمي من اول رمضان
كثفت جهودها انه فريقها او حتى شخصيا انه
تكون لها بوسترات غير رسميه من المسلسل
بوسات هذه هي اللي يمكن احنا نقول اللي
خلتني شان المسلسل حتى قبل الناس ما
تشوفون المسلسل المشكله انه في البوسترات
ظهرت الفنانه حياه الفهد بصوره مثلنا احنا
مو متعودين عليها يعني طلعت بملابس كاجوال
ولابسه كاب وموضوع كان حساسي طرحت ان
الموضوع يكون يعني درامي فريق يقول ان
مستوحى من قصه حقيقيه حدثت مع رجل في احد
الدول حيث سجل لمده 30 سنه ظلما ثم خرج
وحصل على تعويض مالي كبير لكنه بلا ابناء
على عكس كلثوم في مسلسل قاره عينك اذ انها
تمتلك ابناء منهم اربعه بنات لكن يبدو ان
القصه لم تعجب الكثيرين الموضوع الاختيار
للفنان هو موضوع اساسي جدا سواء كان يعني
الفنان الجديد او فنان القدير اليوم فنانه
كبيره نفس حياه الفهد تكون الدقيقه في
اختيارها هي دقيقه في هي قدمت مسلسل سنوات
الجيش كان بصوره الشعبيه بس لازم يكونوا
هم اذكياء في الاختيار اللي تتعامل مع
جمهور شرس جدا اليوم خصوصا في السوشيال
ميديا والان نتوقف مع بعض تغريدات الجمهور
حول العمل
[موسيقى]
لا تشوفين الزجاجه فاضيه لا تطلعين الحين
انا بنتها وردتها الله بالخير حريمكم
يدرونكم عندي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]